Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here!
Pixar's latest offering, Finding Dory, sees
the animated hit-makers dip their toes back
into the sea of sequels after treating us
to two original features last year.
A follow-up to 2003's Finding Nemo, Finding
Dory sees the forgetful blue tang move from
side-kick to centre-stage in a fishy tale
which focuses on her search for her long-lost
parents.
Screenwriters Victoria Strouse and Andrew
Stanton, who also directs alongside Angus
MacLane, have rounded out Dory's character,
highlighting not just her sweet and funny
side, but also lending her more depth, revealing
the fears and worries she faces due to her
short-term memory loss.
And as the voice of Dory, Ellen DeGeneres
is fantastic at bringing all those different
shades of her character to life.
This time we also get a young version of Dory
too.
The way she's animated in flashbacks is oh-so
adorably cute, and Sloane Murray and Lucia
Geddes do a great job lending their voices
to baby and tween versions of the absent-minded
fish.
As well as bringing back several Finding Nemo
fixtures including Nemo himself and his dad
Marlin, Finding Dory introduces us to a whole
range of wonderful new characters.
Of the newcomers, a grumpy but ingenious seven-tentacled
octopus called Hank, who's brilliantly voiced
by Modern Family star Ed O'Neill, gets the
lion's share of screentime.
And what a fantastic addition he is to this
underwater world, making a great odd couple
with Dory, providing tons of laughs and extra
heart too.
As the near-sighted whale shark Destiny and
the rather melodramatic beluga whale Bailey,
Kaitlin Olson and Modern Family's Ty Burrell
add loads of lovely moments, playing really
well off each other and also Ellen's Dory.
And Idris Elba and Dominic West's sunbathing
sea lions are an absolute hoot!
There are also some pretty cool cameos in
the film, with one in particular used in a
clever way that's guaranteed to bring a big
smile to your face whenever you hear it.
As you'd expect from Pixar, the animation
is top-notch, with an array of gorgeous scenes
set in familiar and new ocean locations from
the coral reef to kelp forests, and lots of
interesting land-bound locales provided by
a rehabilitation centre for aquatic life on
the California coast.
There is a feeling about Finding Dory that
we're retreading some of the same water we
covered in Finding Nemo, both thematically
and in terms of some of the ocean-set scenes
in particular, and it's not as nuanced as
Pixar's best, but there's still lots of fun
to be had with some great characters, humorous
moments, and action-filled sequences that
make the movie worth watching, as well as
an underlying message about disability that
deserves to be heard.
And while Pixar's last feature, The Good Dinosaur,
had more grown-up humour than I first expected
in a movie that was more squarely pitched
at kids than say, Inside Out; Finding Dory
doesn't quite hit the creatively clever heights
that we've come to expect of Pixar when it
comes to adult laughs, though you'll still
find a decent number of them.
By the way, if you're an easter egg hunter,
don't forget to keep your eyes peeled throughout,
and I'll have my video guide to the movie's
easter eggs right here when it's ready.
Oh, and if you usually dash out of the cinema
as soon as the film proper's finished, just
be aware that there are some lovely animated
moments during the credits and at the very
end of the credits there's a little treat
too, so make sure you don't miss that!
So, to sum up: Finding Dory isn't quite unforgettable,
but it is beautifully animated and full of
warmth, and features a nice mix of colourful
characters and a voice cast who really deliver
the goods.
And while it's not a 100% fresh catch of the
day, overall, it's plenty enjoyable and entertaining.
And on top of that, the short film, Piper,
which screens before Finding Dory is a lovely
little delight.
Finding Dory gets 4 out of 5 Flicks.
Now, what did you think of Finding Dory?
And what's your favourite Pixar movie and
why?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this review, I'd love it if you'd
share it, and do subscribe for more movie
reviews, Easter Egg videos and amazing movie
facts!
Click the links here to check those out!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!